University Medical Center in Las Vegas
is the only level 1 trauma center in all
of Nevada the hospital is capable of
treating a wide range of patients 24
hours a day staff treated many of the
wounded from Sunday's attack dr. John
files is the trauma centers medical
director good morning doctor thank you
so much for joining us good morning
I know that you took in more than a
hundred patients yesterday the scene
there was described as a warzone how did
you deal with it when we were notified
of the shooting we went into our
disaster plan and went through the phone
tree and we brought in staff many many
surgeons anesthesiologist nurses techs
and as the flow of patients started to
rise we were able to assign them to
teams and move them through the
resuscitation area and then we opened up
new parts of the hospital as hospital
wards and we were able to get them in
beds and continue their care describe
the type of injuries
we saw mostly gunshot wounds but we also
saw injuries that were sustained in
people fleeing the scene for example
some people had fallen others had been
pedestrians struck by vehicles in the
chaos and so as they came in we sorted
them out along those lines
can I ask you at this point how many of
the patients that you've received how
many of them are still on the critical
list what's their condition
about a quarter of them are still
considered critical and we've downgraded
3/4 of them to stable condition at this
point so what's the total number of that
still in critical
that's gonna be about 25
25 about 25 critical
what are the types of recoveries and
operations still needed for those in
critical condition well they can include
operations on the abdomen ongoing care
for penetrating wounds in the chest
there are a number of patients who have
vascular injuries in the extremities
that are still being watched and worked
on and there are a fair number of
orthopedic injuries that have to be
managed I understand that it just so
happens that UMC recently consulted with
doctors and physicians from Orlando what
were some of the lessons learned we
received a presentation from the doctors
in Orlando as part of a combined program
with metro to understand what the in
hospital experience was after the pulse
nightclub shooting and it gave us a
different frame of reference to work
from when we combine that with our
regular disaster drills it created a
really good platform for us to work off
in this situation
and how are the staff members of UMC
doing you know when you walk around
they're all really tired but there's
beaming with pride right now
we're dr. John files I know it's been a
long almost couple of days now so thanks
to you and all of your staff there at
the hospital thank you so much thank you